when did the pineapple thing start none
of you fans get to see this this was an
awesome little streamer tutorial here
for any streamers looking to improve
their
setup this seems like a beautiful place
to set up the headquarters of the most
watched chess streams ever let's go see
how it happens hello hello is hi Caro
here wrong
address just
kidding all right we're in we're here
with aaro and there he is there how's it
going Danny I was just in town wow
that's surprising yeah I guess but why
are you at my house I just wanted to see
where the uh where it all goes down yeah
well why not let's take a look at where
the magic happens man this is the uh
where the magic happens I've got my
camera on I've got my whole setup here
of course classic puzzle Rush everything
else I've never seen this shelf over
here this has not been opened it's a 4x4
Rubik's Cube I don't know who gifted it
to me I think my mom did or maybe my
brother did years ago um that of course
is a twitch plugin it lights up if you
plug it in I have this little Cube which
actually uh is from December 9th 1993
you can actually see right there so uh
it was actually carved I think by my
biological father and this of course is
my name so that's pretty cool pretty
cool stuff then of course we got this
nice controller to be used obviously and
anybody who streams has to be a gamer
can't just be playing chess that's just
not fun this is ridiculous this shelf of
course is the uh special one this is the
one that everyone gets to see yes
exactly this has some pretty special
stuff first of all I have this Grand
chest tour thing which I won when I won
the Paris grandchester event in 2018
okay this is Valen care the the winner
this was a gift from the um from a fan I
think during the Fay candidates in U
Madrid someone bought me this like it's
like a hologram of U of the stadium the
Real Madrid stadium kind of cool but
this is from the uh millionaire chest T
2015 when I won oh my gosh yeah that's
epic that's a play button for my second
Channel more Jam hikaro for 100,000 and
otherwise it's all got a little green
pond here little chest a little chess.
comp Pond that nobody gets to sees it's
like the smallest thing here the out of
all things kind of kind of random yeah
yeah this was actually my parents bought
this for me in Hawaii I think last year
just a nice little Hawaiian that's
pretty pineapple trinket and this I've
never really used but that actually
lights up if you plug it in so it's a
big pineapple when did the pineapple
thing start chess teacher this guy comes
with a pineapple shirt to teach you a
metal and he says yeah a GM in chess I
would say go back to B bottle
that started in the middle of 2020
during the pandemic specifically there
was a forest stream on Twitch where his
community made a joke out of me watching
it I was wearing actually this pineapple
shirt that I'm wearing now so they
started making the joke about the
pineapple man in the pineapple house
under the sea and it just stuck so I I
keep with it and also even beyond that I
mean pineapple I think is the main fruit
in Hawaii and I've gone there many many
times so we have a chess.com logo there
thank you
thank you this amazing well and then
we've got this angle here we're not
going to show anything incriminating on
screen there's there's nothing
incriminating I mean I can obviously
just show you guys it's pretty
straightforward yeah so I was going to
like what I do normally is my setup is
pretty straightforward if I'm streaming
on Twitch I'll have the chat basically
popped out right up here I'll just
extend this I have my dashboard via
streamlabs click on recent events
normally I'll have like OBS open as well
so I'll just have like OBS just one
second I have OBS over here and then on
this monitor is where I do it so I guess
just for fun we'll do one do one puzzle
Rush see how many I can get let's go
check for the record I standing in the
fair play cam position exactly none of
you fans get to see this except for when
a nich giri inappropriately leaks things
on Twitter we're going to talk to you
about that in um but this is where the
fair play cam would sit right here
looking at Hikaru his Mouse his monitor
so for anyone who's ever wondering what
it looks like we got to keep watching
him over here he's crush he's crushing
this puzzle Rush all pretty good
actually there we go I I got to speed up
though I'm a little bit too slow right
now should be checking bishop4 takes
oops oh that was that was a mouse flip
because I I thought I was going to play
another move in the puzzle oh darn I
should have got him 54 53 was pretty
good though 53 was good yeah that was
pretty good I should have gotten 54 if I
played Rook H1 quicker but it was pretty
awesome and this was an awesome little
streamer tutorial here for any streamers
looking to improve their setup exactly
yes welcome to hikaro world yeah and
then I have my drinks always which
everyone always everyone always sees my
my glass and of course my my coffee mug
I i' i' I rotate a few of these mugs but
this is the one I'm using right now so
so fans watching this video are lucky
they've seen everything now yeah yeah
that's true yep thanks for having me
yeah no problem I I hope you enjoy the
tour and bye everybody and car Nakamura
streaming cribs I don't know how to
unlock door hold on I have to get out of
here okay bye everybody thank you bye
bye